[Music]
all right ryan
yes brian where'd you grow up where are
you from originally where am i from
originally i'm originally i was born in
chicago illinois
i was raised in florida my whole life
south florida pompano beach
tell me about your family growing up
yeah mom and dad yeah i had my mom and
dad they were together for about i don't
know a little less than half my life
um
it was a very uh very abusive situation
as far as i can remember um me and my
mother took the burn of the abuse
the other the other children really
didn't uh
they know about it they didn't really
get to see too much of it me and my mom
kind of protected them
you know i mean away from that i'm the
oldest in my family you know i mean i
have all the children so you know what i
mean um
basically i went through everything
first and kind of protected them how
would you describe your childhood
my childhood um i don't really
i think that i don't had i don't know i
really didn't have much of a childhood
like i didn't watch
tv uh
i didn't get to watch movies i didn't
really play play with friends and
you know after school and stuff like
that it was always uh i was terrified of
my father for the most part you know i
remember not wanting him to come home
but yet i loved him to death you know i
mean
by the way he just passed away like
seven months ago so it was kind of crazy
but um
uh that and my sister was my best friend
you know my the oldest of my two sisters
and my best friend
my mom
she's really always been a lion
conniving person you know what i mean um
as far as i can remember she's been
lying to my father and that that's
you know i found out later on in life a
lot of the abuse came from
the lying and my dad not being able to
handle it he always went overseas to
hong kong
uh selling uh bootleg clothes for my uh
grandfather
they ended up getting arrested and sued
by levi stross and reebok and nike for
millions of dollars and put my whole
family into a hole that we haven't been
out of since
you know what i mean um
and my grandpa just passed away
finally so um
but yeah man and he passed away in
prison
you know what i mean at 88 years old it
was kind of insane
um
my two grandmothers are awesome they're
loving they're caring they're
god-fearing women you know i mean my
family
it's pretty much a god-fearing family
you know what i mean um
but around the time my parents got
divorced i got kicked out of the house
and uh for threatening the guy who ended
up becoming my stepfather
um you know i seen him in bed with my
mom and it just it wasn't didn't set
right you know what i mean
so i i i tried to shoot him and um
well i got kicked out yeah what agent
huh what how old were you i was 12.
um
the only friend i had was ah i had a
friend named gladys man i haven't seen
in a long time but gladys
gladys was also kicked out of her house
at the same age and uh she was involved
with some gang members down in miami
florida
and uh
that was my new family
you know what i mean i became a part of
that gang
and uh
i got shot
you know i got stabbed um our house got
burnt down one time um
every any any bad story you could think
of uh you know coming with the gang life
you know i was there i did it um
it happened to me you know i did my got
my first charge when i was like 13 years
old and i've been getting arrested ever
since
um i probably i think it was like 40
something felonies i caught before i was
18.
um went to a boot camp that
she was supposed to save my life like
from me having to go do years in prison
as a juvenile
so they gave me an option to go to this
level 10
fully hands-on boot camp meaning they
are allowed to beat your ass
you know what i mean and they did
and
um it was probably the worst experience
one of one of the worst experiences of
my life
um definitely one of the worst
experience of my juvenile life because
uh i didn't know i was going my dad
tricked me so i thought i was going to
work
you know what i mean and he pulled up
and he was like well since i can't get
you straightened up son and you're gonna
be living here
you know i mean and so i'm supposed to
get out in a year and i was there for
almost two years you know what i mean
cutting up fighting
running into other people that claimed
other gangs you know
through all that bull crap how far did
you go to school huh how far did you go
in school i graduated college you did i
i have graduated college um
in that boot camp that i was at i uh i
went to uh
they couldn't find my i was in a private
school for bad kids before i went to
that boot camp before i got locked up in
that boot camp so conventional school
how far did you go
ninth grade before i got locked up okay
and i know you did like ged uh
no when i went there they couldn't find
out my transcripts so when they gave me
a placement test i scored out halfway
through 11th grade
and uh and that was just i don't know
i've always kind of been academically
all right like without even studying
um
just as long as somebody talks about it
i'll hear it i'll take it in and put it
to use but
uh yeah that was kind of funny because i
ended up graduating high school from
vero beach high school a year early
at 17 years old you know what i mean
and uh it was pretty crazy how that
happened but yeah i walked it cap and
gown i walked the stage you know i mean
no ged he's high school diploma and you
went to college and then i went to
florida atlantic university after that
what were you looking to do with your
life uh i did not go there
let's say i didn't go there on my own
will i um i went there because somebody
wanted me to take a class
basically so they could utilize me
in their company you know and it was my
father
and i took a construction project
coordination
class and i got my business management
degree you know i got a ba and um
i'll tell you like this i i hated it i
was so cool that i graduated college i
was really
cool with that but
he stopped me from going to the school
that i wanted to go to
for what i wanted to go to it for
in order to like help his dreams come
true
and like i resented him a lot for that
you know i didn't want to i don't like
construction not one bit but i know
everything about it the back of my hand
you know i mean i could run a whole site
build a hotel for you whatever
but i hate it you know what i mean i
i wouldn't want to do it so nevertheless
i graduated salutatorian in my class not
valid victorian but salutatorian it's
like second highest in in class
and um
and i only did that because
it was a challenge to me so i was like
you know what even though i don't like
this i'm still going to try to be
try to be best you know what i mean
so i'm real challenging type of person
you know what i mean i like to
i like to uh compete you know what i
mean and when i compete i like to win
you know every time type stuff so like
um
you know that that wave of college
you know when i graduated it was like
dead right there and
except i did use
what i learned as far as contracts and
business contracts i started rewriting
contracts for my father's company i got
out of uh
boot camp and got out of college and i
started you know working for my father i
ran my father's company for more than 10
years you know what i mean um
we brought it from
i think his company was like drowning
making like 180 000 a year as soon as i
put in the five-year contracts and he
had like these two year contracts for
contract cleaning company
i redid all the contracts and was
locking people in them for five years i
brought his company up to 1.2 million
the first year
you know what i mean and um i was a
sales representative i was also the
supervisor i just i was on salary full
time doing whatever for my father's
company and um i specialize in floors uh
marble tile
granite stuff like that uh polyurethane
floors whatever kind of floor you can
think of i could use a layer to refinish
it
um
also you know we we get contracts with
banks i clean the banks you know what
i'm saying and really i was just a
supervisor you know agenda how'd you end
up down here
oh i ended up down here it's kind of
crazy um
so
after all this stuff with me working my
dad and stuff you know i did get i got
married
to somebody who's my best friend
um at the time
you know i loved her since i was a
little kid so
long story short it didn't last long we
had a son named dominic he's about to be
18 now
and he's bigger than me
and um
well
i had him for the first three years of
his life
some really bad stuff happened between
me and his mother and my father got
involved and
somehow they they betrayed me and my son
got taken from me and given to her
i flipped out
i needed to get up about ten thousand
dollars for a lawyer i did it by any
means possible which was illegal drug
trades
and i got arrested i got set up by
somebody that i knew for 15 years and i
went to prison i was my first adult case
i went to prison for three years
and uh
and they've been telling my son's lives
lies about me ever since and um
in that time i thought that i would
never go back to prison again um
i saw some things that you can't imagine
you know i did some things that you
couldn't imagine
um to keep myself safe you know what i'm
saying but i told you you know i got
involved with gangs on the street so
when you're in there
you know
imagine all the gangs but compressed
compact and all living in the same area
you know what i mean so it's like always
you the guy you hates right there all
the time
all the time so
um
i mean if you want me to go into like a
little bit of the prison stories that's
right that's right or not but uh you
said what let's hear it okay
i just had a guy before you that told me
something pretty hurt so i had a guy i
had a friend named brandon these i say
because prison there's parts of prison
they're like [ __ ] up and there's parts
that traumatized me all right and like
i'm just going to go with parts of
traumatizing because that's what sticks
out
brandon was 18 this guy named brandon i
took my little trip up the road with him
you know we sat next to to each other on
the bus and got transfers for some
reason we always kept getting
transferred together so that was my road
dog that was my little home he was
younger than me
and i could tell that he was green he
didn't know nothing
and um
well
this black guy from miami named doo doo
[ __ ] doo doo doo doo
um
well dude been him at that time dudu had
been down 22 years and had a life
sentence okay
i mean he's a big black guy named dude
what do you think they call him doo doo
you know what i mean
he likes playing in your doo-doo you
know what i'm saying
so and it's pretty nasty and he was
giving my friend drugs and [ __ ] like
that in prison and he was doing it for
free
my mom wasn't buying them he's handing
them xanax bars which is a notorious
like
rape drug you know what i mean
uh
just giving them coffee and everything
never asking for nothing back and i told
my homeboy this is crazy i sat down with
him the same day and i said listen
if you can't see what's going on with
doo doo i'm going to tell you one time
and if you continue i'm cutting you off
bro i can't you're only as good as the
company you keep i will not keep that
type of company near me
so he says what's going on i said okay
so
doo doo he likes you man he's trying
he's trying he's trying to [ __ ] you bro
straight up
and um i don't know how it makes you
feel but it pisses me off
makes me feel violated inside in all
kinds and it's not even me you know what
i mean
i was like bro you're only 18 you got
your whole life ahead of you you're only
doing an 18 month bid bro you know what
i'm saying don't [ __ ] with people like
that you know what i'm saying if you
need some coffee bro you need something
like that bro i got it in a locker come
get it from me bro no strings attached
you don't need [ __ ]
you know what i mean
well
same day you know that [ __ ] went in one
ear and out the other because the same
day not even [ __ ] an hour later i go
to my my room
and uh his room his cell block was in
between my
room and the shower
so i get up i go i leave take a shower a
little bit later and as i'm coming back
i smell one of the worst smells i've
ever smelled in my life
and it just happened to be when i was
like right about to be at his door like
passing the door
so like as i smelt and realized where i
was standing i was like oh no
and i took a step forward and i looked
in the room and there was brandon butt
naked face down passed out with blood
and [ __ ] all over his bed
all right
now that right there
sent me into a whole different mind
frame of life like i had never been the
same since i was never the same person
ever that
ever since that happened i've never seen
i've never been the same person
you know i've never been uh
something was broke right there
something got broken in me you know what
i mean
that you can't fix because you can't
even see that [ __ ]
you know i mean that was at martin ci in
florida and the same the same month i
seen a guy's guts
uh fall out of his stomach man that [ __ ]
was nuts and i was it was a prison yard
little gang thing i don't know he
violated amongst his gang i don't know
the whole story but
but i saw the whole thing you know what
i mean and the guy was running for help
and he
when he [ __ ] finally fell down he
went like this and his guts
kind of were falling out and he was dead
on the yard by about a good five ten
minutes before anybody even knew
before the the helicopter was even
called or anything like that and um
you know
i never thought i remember my father and
my sister coming to to uh
to vizzo and they were just looking
around and i hadn't told them nothing i
never told them none of this [ __ ]
and
they were looking around and they could
kind of see the yard from the visiting
park
they were like
man
please come home please make it home
like are you sure are you sure you're
okay here because like i'll make phone
calls and get you moved i said you will
not make no phone calls about me i'm
good you know what i'm saying you don't
need to you don't need to call no
authorities about me or nothing i'll be
fine you know what i mean so boom i made
it out of prison you know what i mean
made it out of prison uh i stabbed
doodoo in the face
um and it wasn't because of brandon it
was because uh he disrespected me in the
in the
in the tv room he changed the channel i
told him i was watching that he said
well what the [ __ ] you gonna do about it
cracker [ __ ] i said oh okay well i
already know what i got to do about it
now that was my first stabbing in prison
that was the first time i actually put
in work in prison
you know what i mean and i didn't put in
work for nobody else you know that was
myself it was for myself my safety and
my respect
you know what i mean
and um
you know sadly enough
the only thing i learned from that was
how hard
you have to um
you have to
hit somebody in order for the thing to
go through their skin you know and the
sound it makes it pop since
it was so different than what i thought
it was gonna be it [ __ ] me up
you know i mean it [ __ ] me up man
because i'm a nice guy i don't like to
be violent i just thought it was going
to be like a little you know sharp 1-2
thing and i just leave but no
it was deeper than that
anyway
he went to uh protective custody i got
out of prison eventually you know what i
mean he never told them yet i got out of
prison um the funny thing is my second
bit in prison
guess who walked up on me on the yard
dude
walked up right behind me he said no i
could have killed your ass
he said but i like you i like your style
and i like how you roll
turn around i was like oh [ __ ]
i'm not gonna lie i was i was probably
terrified inside i didn't look like it
but i was probably terrified
um
and so that's
second bit in prison and you know i've
already at this point i've already been
through this divorce with my first wife
my son's growing up and trying to stay
in his life and it's all it's all
turmoil now i'm heavy in drug use and
i can't get out of that i'm trapped in a
web where it's like
i'm doing drugs because i just got me so
much pain and then
uh
i can't and i mean there's no point not
doing them because when i come out of
them my baby mom is still [ __ ] with
me not let me see my son my my people
are still talking [ __ ] there's no point
so the only thing i had to turn to was
drugs you know what i mean
that was my
that was my that was my getaway it was
my you know my painkiller
so um
not to mention you know i've been to
prison five times
i've done 13 and a half years in prison
all together
um
one of the times i went to one of the
five commitments that i have
my
fifth commitment was
caught while i was already in there i
was doing two years and i was 31 days
away from going home
i caught five more years
it's another stabbing um
guy told me he didn't kill me
i told him well thanks for notifying me
buddy
you know what i mean i was being smart
ass dinner time came around
i went out to chow hall and did what i
was supposed to do
you know what i mean um
he didn't tell on me although i did get
a little trouble for it
um
he didn't tell on me but i caught five
more years for it you know what i mean
so
that was that but in between all this
time i wanted to tell you this you know
i've been a musician the whole time
you asked me how i got to california
um
i got to california because
when i got out of prison this last
prison bid that i did i was running i
was doing tattoos as a business you know
i was doing all right in northern
florida
um had a new girlfriend i had i had a
little bit of a life going on not much
but a little something and like four
o'clock in the morning my phone call my
phone rings and it's this guy jeff
who billy also knows bill billy also
knows this guy
he brought billy out here and uh
jeff says man
got a record label we got some deals on
the table for you right now
there's a plane ticket at the airport
for you tomorrow 12 o'clock in the
afternoon
if you [ __ ] miss it you miss it but
it won't be another opportunity
so i said wow
i said well bro i got these people who
gave me down payments
for these tattoos man i can't i can't
just dip on them and leave like that you
know what i mean say man you better bro
because we're not talking some little
petty chains we're not talking 100 bucks
here 50 bucks there
we're we're talking we're we're in the
millions you know we're talking about a
record deal bro
and i'm like [ __ ] man he sent me the
um
receipt for my ticket for my plane
ticket and they flew me first class out
here
so i was like wow i land in l.a and it's
live on my facebook me landing in l.a
you know i mean coming to see some
representative representatives from
capitol records you know what i mean and
um
you know everything that's how i got out
here okay
now
jeff
he's a son of a [ __ ] you know
he's the guy who he ruined my life he
thought he was giving me a life but he
ruined my life and um rory helped ruin
it
and um
you know but i would never let him
try to be my manager he had um
he had what's called uh
not power of attorney but yeah it's like
that um
conservatorship over your money
okay and i had uh struck a deal with a
smaller label
uh
for about half a million dollars
and i was gonna i just sold him the
album outright you know what i mean we
were gonna they were gonna pay for all
the recording everything paid for the
housing i had 490 grand in the bank and
that was it that was me and that's how i
wanted it that's the deal i picked
because i was going to take the 490 000
and make my own label and do my own
thing
you know what i mean
well
jeff
who's now in prison for 10 years
for this
embezzled
about 380 000 was my money
when bank of america froze the account
i called them up like hey what's going
on
they tell me what happened and bam i'm
basically [ __ ] out of luck
until they can find the guy and
prosecute him now he just got prosecuted
you know i mean he just just i mean he
just landed in the federal penitentiary
maybe a week ago
you know i mean so
now i'm supposed to be looking at
starting to get some funds back
but i'm not quite sure i look at it like
it's a lost cause i'll keep in touch
with them see what i you know what they
could do but
you know peace so much so much stuff has
happened since i've been in california
so much crazy stuff that like i'm scared
to tell people like
because i don't think they'll believe me
i think i'll think they think i'm crazy
like what kind of stuff
oh man um
okay so
i'm sure you're familiar with um
man i so don't want to say this
i'm sure you're familiar with gang
stalking yeah okay um
yeah i thought it was complete total
[ __ ] right i was you guys just
[ __ ] left out idiots
and um
you know the people telling me about
this [ __ ] no
well
i started i started uh
i had a girlfriend okay she ended up
calling my phone it's not a girl i
hollered at or nothing it was a girl
that came to me called my phone
beautiful dropped a gorgeous [ __ ] out
in the valley
she hits my phone up
she says she she thanks
uh thanks me for what i'm doing because
every saturday i would go and i would
help the homeless people out at warner
center park and i would bring them fresh
clothes fresh shoes and a bunch of
barbecue and stuff like that
and uh it was all free for them you know
what i mean i paid for it is all free
for them i was selling drugs i was doing
my thing and that's what i did with some
of my proceeds you know what i mean and
um i'll take care of the homeless so
this girl's dad was one of those people
and she called me up and told me she
wanted to thank me for taking care of
her people out here you know what i mean
i said all right you're welcome and
she's like well i just wonder does
anybody ever call you up
ask you how you're doing do you need
anything
i was like [ __ ] no she's like well i'm
i'm calling you up and i'm asking you
are you all right you need anything i
said i bought some
company and uh when i met her and i seen
who she was
man
kelsey you are drop dead gorgeous
she is drop day gorgeous
she
put me on to who gang started were and
honestly i believe that now she's a part
of them
because she ruined me you know what i
mean
long story short i was taking care of
her and her three week old
yeah three week old child
a few months went by
she gets caught with some meth
i asked the police is there any way
that she could come home with me right
now
she said they said well somebody's got
to go in for this i said well it was
mine
it's mine take me to jail then
because i have a record she doesn't have
a record so you know they did they took
the cups off of her put them on me and
they took me to jail
and i only needed 200 to get out
she uh
i told her who to go get the damn money
from and she came back pregnant with his
[ __ ] kid
you know
like what the [ __ ]
who does that [ __ ] you know what i mean
who does that that's the biggest form of
betrayal i've ever i've ever seen in my
life like
what the [ __ ]
you know what i mean
so then when i got out it was the night
before christmas it was christmas eve
and boom i knew something was wrong
whatever found out she cheated on me
this this and then i told her i was
gonna forgive her you know i mean and
basically she didn't want to be forgiven
you know what i mean
so she's pregnant and this whole time
she thinks or she's telling me that uh
you know this is my baby who else could
it be because where the time frames
match there's no way it could be anybody
else's well i went to jail for a year
last year okay she had the baby i got
out
uh she wanted to meet up with me i met
up with her she's like well i didn't
bring the baby this time because i
wanted to show you see who how you were
and stuff like that and so you picture
first you know what i mean but yeah
here's your daughter
shows me the picture and i just started
laughing my ass off
i was like what the [ __ ] is this
and she's like uh
that's that's your daughter i'm like
that's not my [ __ ] daughter that's
that's a mexican baby yes that's a it
looks just like lewis like
like i'm telling you you [ __ ] louis
and she's like
ryan i'm so sorry
this is it on the streets they call me
poet
you know what i mean but
no she's like i'm so sorry i meant to
tell you and this this this and that and
i was just like
oh my god this is so [ __ ] i gotta go
bye
and i got out the car i haven't seen her
since i've talked to her a couple times
i haven't seen her since you know i mean
it's
just she made me
i went from a person who was looked at
in the parts of california that i was in
as a person of some type of status just
a little bit you know to like
this like a joke you know they made me
feel like i'm a joke now like
it's crazy
it's crazy how it is and and and i've
been trying to
break from her threshold because i i did
i fell in love with her so finally i did
break free of that just recently
and um
no matter how bad i tried to
rekindle my relationship with
kelsey it just didn't work it's not
gonna work and i'm glad i'm glad now
it didn't work um
i've only had one other relationship
since then it was very very short
um are you staying now huh where you
stay now i i i'm
uh boom i'm staying in the rv but really
you know i'm on the streets you know i
mean i'm on streets uh
trying as hard as i can
to to to get a actual home you know what
i mean but
i got a friend that's allowing me to
stay in an rv down here and then i have
a friend in antelope valley which i go
to every weekend and i stay in a really
nice rv
for the weekend
uh
that i really want to move up there i
hate the weather up there but i want to
move up into that that place is like
actual i could call that rv a home you
know what i mean what's uh what's your
drug nut huh what's your drug no my drug
of choice
oh man uh fentanyl
i use uh you said no i can't get off of
it um i've tried
i can't
and um
people don't even like me when i'm
trying to get off of it i become
very uh depressed
you're just a down type of person like
that i just want to get off of it
because there's so much to me than that
you know i mean
there's so much
way more to me than that than just drugs
and
somebody tried to poison me while i was
here
i don't know if you've ever seen a
portable little water kit it's like the
thing you get a cvs they're made of
silicone or rubber and that's why i used
to pour my water in so that i could draw
it out and shoot up right listen to this
somebody replaced it with freon
okay
somebody tried to kill me they replaced
it with freon and i was shooting this
[ __ ] for two to three days
okay
and i noticed that 30 minutes after each
shot i would projectile vomit everywhere
it was horrible and i was like what the
hell is going on what the hell is going
on
finally i uh
after checking i checked out the dope i
checked out my dope dealer i checked out
everybody who lived with me everything
finally the one thing that i hadn't
checked out yet was my water
checked out the water i poured in a cup
and it's like neon green
i was like oh my god that was like freon
what the hell i smell it i was like oh
my god
so i took it to um
i took it to i called poison control
stuff like that and i took it to they
told me to go hospital i took it to the
doctor
i said this this is
i've been shooting this on accident
and he told me what it was
and it was freon and he freeze he also
uh
told me i should be dead you know what i
mean
um
needless to say i don't use a rig
anymore because all my veins are dead
because of it i can't use any needle
anymore you know what i mean
so now i
smoke fentanyl but um
what would you say is your biggest
regret
my biggest regret
there's one part that i haven't got to
just yet
and this is uh probably because it's the
worst
most deepest
darkest part of my life and um
i got remarried before i left florida
okay
i uh i neglected to tell you this in
2014 my wife and my daughter passed away
all right and um
i lost it you died right in front of me
they were killed they were not [ __ ]
nothing i was straight up
[ __ ] murdered
you know what i'm saying but
by the people who are supposed to save
you
which is the
doctors that doctor's in jail right now
you know god won my i want my lawsuit
um
how did they die
well my daughter had a blood clot in her
heart and i guess it sent warning signs
to my my wife my wife had a seizure we
were in an apartment then she had a
massive heart attack
she had a massive heart attack she
stopped breathing i know cpr from being
through marine corps boot camp and stuff
like that i gave her cpr brought her
back to life later on her side and told
her everything was okay we'll be there a
minute
so boom
uh the ambulance took forever to come
they went to the wrong hospital
then they went to the wrong hospital
again but at least that one had a nicu
which is a nursery for babies because
she was seven and a half months pregnant
i guess the law is any complications
after seven months pregnant they're
taking the baby out immediately within
the first 15 minutes of being there put
them in an incubator so they can finish
up the growth of the respiratory system
and that'll be that right trust me i've
looked into it i shoot the [ __ ] out of
these people
i've looked into it deeply and um
well they didn't do any of that
they went to the wrong hospital first
time taking their sweet ass time went to
the wrong hospital again but whatever
we'll deal with because they got a nicu
there and they're supposed to be world
renowned best hospital you know what i
mean especially for cardio you know
[ __ ] what ended up happening was
they asked me uh they they told me that
i did a good job giving her cpr and then
i saved both my wife and my daughter's
life right
okay
well uh
then they asked me for my insurance
and i gave them obamacare
getting my obamacare card and their
whole demeanor changed and one of the
ladies actually spoke these words and
said obama doesn't pay none of his bills
so i got scared right off the rip i was
like obama
what does that have to do with me
you know i mean in hersh
so we went from we're going to be in
operation in 15 minutes and your
daughter's gonna be born a day early
then
uh
went from that to
i don't even know where these people are
they haven't even come back in their
room yet and when they finally do come
back in the room they say oh the baby's
heartbeat is slowing down too much you
guys are right now they take her out
they hand it to me she dies in my arms
okay
my newborn daughter died right there in
my arms
i watched her take her last breath
and i was [ __ ]
so piece of me right there got [ __ ]
ripped out
and um
i didn't know what to tell jesse i
already knew there was there was a storm
coming when jesse woke up
and found this out
so finally she woke up and she asked me
uh
where the baby's at
i told her just going back to sleep you
know
i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm supposed
to tell her what am i supposed to tell
her
so uh
she said
ryan you better tell me where the [ __ ]
my daughter is right now
i say oh she
she went home a little early you know
she just went home early
she's gone
what do you want me to say
and she [ __ ] flipped she
flipped she flipped out and um
she started telling doctor how she was
gonna sue him and all that [ __ ]
and um
you know
i don't know man she's uh the doctor
ended up
what ended up happening was the doctor
after she was threatening the doctor
saying i'm gonna sue you and this this
this that and you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
you know i keep telling her to be quiet
she needs to chill
you know what i mean um
her teeth like locked up in front of me
like her jaw is locked up while she was
flipping out like that and her lips went
pale and she had another seizure
and uh so i call a doctor and they they
get her back stable real quick or
whatever and
they tell me uh you know because i was
legally married to her they tell me that
i got to sign off on on the operation
that she has all of a sudden has
internal bleeding in her spleen
i said how can she have internal
bleeding in her spleen she hasn't done
nothing to cause that
they're like oh you know sometimes they
get hit or bumped i was like are you
crazy you think i
i wouldn't hit her or bump her
you know what i mean so um
what ended up happening was um
they took her they said the spleen was
bleeding
they took her in for the operation
they brought her back to me and they
said i'm sorry i nicked our nictory
order artery
she's internally bleeding and i can't
stop it and she's only got about a
minute left
so and she heard it she was awake when
he said that
and
i was like what
and this idiot told me it would be too
dangerous to go in there and try to
try to singe the artery i said you idiot
my whole family works in a hospital i
know all about about this [ __ ] all you
have to do if you nicked their aorta
artery number one why did you sew her
back up and bring her to me without
singing it you know what i mean without
burning a shot why did you do that
you know what i mean
long story short
a minute and a half later my wife looked
at me in my eyes and she died
she kissed me and died
right there in [ __ ]
holy cross [ __ ] ass hospital
you know what i mean
and um
and i just i felt i felt i felt the life
go out of here i felt like go i ran i
i snapped i beat the doctor
half to death
i uh i caused a really big scene in that
er they shut down the
the whole icu
they shut down that whole fourth floor
of the hospital
because they were scared of what i might
do and they locked me in the room with
her
and so i laid in the bed with her for
about two hours and just
just held him and broke down and cried
you know
and um
finally they told me that uh
i needed to come on because rigor mortis
was about to kick in
and they didn't want me to freak out
when i seen that kick in because i might
mistake it and think she's still alive i
don't know do you know what ricker
mortis is
not exactly when the body starts to move
after his dead the body will twitch
they'll even sit up sometimes
they're completely dead but
the you know the nerves make the muscles
do [ __ ] and they'll sit up you know what
i mean or
[ __ ] move your arm or something it's
called rigor mortis
and um
so they didn't want me to be around for
that because they've seen it traumatize
people before
people
thinking that they were alive and then
basically watching their family member
die all over again you know what i mean
and um
so yeah
jesse was the [ __ ] man that was my wife
that was the best part of my whole life
was uh my wife my second wife
and i named my daughter after my sister
so that was a really bad thing i don't
know
i [ __ ] my sister up
i [ __ ] my whole family up
but uh
my dad got me out of trouble
because i hurt that doctor and i heard
some nurses i heard a lot of people in
the hospital that day i think there was
like 12 felonies they tried to pull up
on me and uh
my dad does some donations to the
[ __ ]
broadway county sheriff's department
down in florida so uh
i don't know how he did it but he called
the uh chief of police and he got me out
of trouble
you know i was able to um i was told
that i was able to go say goodbye to my
wife one last time and i had to leave
the hospital right then and there
so one thing i said sam is i'm not going
to leave until i called i got a problem
i have my own coroner come and pick her
up
because i don't trust none of you guys
and guess what
autopsy reads that there was nothing
wrong with her spleen and it was never
even removed
he's blatant negligent homicide
the doctor straight killed my
wife made up a story and killed my wife
you know i mean made up a story to uh
perform operation lawsuit or settlement
i'm in the middle of it right now i'm
still in the middle of it and actually
we're like this close we we won he just
he's able to do a
an appeal like three times or whatever
so he's trying to appeal it but that
guy's going that guy's going to prison
forever he's going to prison and i'm
getting
you know 30 well i gotta pay 33
of a 32.4 million dollar lawsuit
but [ __ ] the lawsuit that [ __ ] can't
bring my family back you know
since then my family's just been slowly
falling apart
ever like now i'm on my own i'm out here
i haven't seen my family since then
it's 2014.
me and my family are supposed to be like
this
i haven't seen them or touched them
since then
you know what i mean so
hopefully i can get back to florida i'm
trying to find the money to take take a
trip back to florida even if it's for
two or three days
i need to go one trip to florida one
trip to chicago so i can see my people
because i feel like maybe
i might never get to see him again
because i never got to see my dad or my
grandpa ever again
you know what i mean
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in all of this
oh wow
oh wow i don't know um
honestly i'm still so confused
at why it happened
um
uh
well i could say this
to come maybe not with that topic right
there but you know my whole life the
most the one thing that complicated my
life the most was probably drugs you
know what i mean
you take the drugs out and you take a
lot of a lot of other problems out
but then again you might catch somebody
me myself i might have committed suicide
if i didn't have the drugs you know
i've tried a couple times and for some
reason it didn't work
you know what i mean i've done things
like crash the ducati on accident at 82
miles an hour no helmet no gear and i
got up with no scratch
that happened here in
california you know what i mean
but like i it's just certain things i
can't explain and the gang stalker thing
is like
i lost sight of who is me i think that
uh my ex was involved in that and
you know she stole my phone she locked
me out of my google she locked me on my
facebook she took away every contact
that i ever knew so that any contact i
knew from there on out was only through
her
so whatever she told them to do
they did cut me off she cut me off do
this they did that and
you know
i've been jumped out here a couple times
[ __ ] just a month and a half and a half
ago i got stabbed right up the street at
macarthur park
you know what i mean for what reason i
have no idea
you know what i mean but it's been a
wild ride
you know what i mean and
i caught a lot of stripes in prison you
know i mean i've already caught all my
stripes man i've done everything you
i've done everything
pretty much if you ask me on you know if
it was on your mind have you done this
did you have to do that
yeah i've just never been gay and i've
never been a snitch you know what i'm
saying but all the gangster [ __ ] that
you think you have to do yeah i had to
do it you know
but my biggest lesson is
uh i wish uh
i wish i would have never started drugs
up again you know i wish i would
probably say taking my mental health
meds
all right
poet thank you so much for sharing your
story all right man thank you good luck
you